Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Have a look at these beautiful ferrofluid
simulations from a previous paper.
These are fluids that have magnetic properties
and thus respond to an external magnetic field,
and you are seeing correctly, they are able
to even climb things.
And the best part is that simulator was so
accurate that we could run it side-by-side
with real-life footage, and see that they
run very similarly.
Excellent.
Now, running these simulations took a considerable
amount of time.
To address this, a followup paper appeared
that showcased a surface-only formulation.
What does that mean?
Well, a key observation here was that for
a class of ferrofluids, we don’t have to
compute how the magnetic forces act on the
entirety of the 3D fluid domain, we only have
to compute them on the surface of the model.
So what does this get us?
Well, these amazing fluid labyrinths, and
all of these ferrofluid simulations, but…
faster!
So, remember, the first work did something
new, but took a very long time, and the second
work improved it to make it faster and more
practical.
Please remember this for later in this video.
And now let’s fast forward to today’s
paper, this new work can also simulate ferrofluids,
and not only that, but also supports a broader
range of magnetic phenomena, including rigid
and deformable magnetic bodies and two-way
coupling too!
Oh my!
That is sensational, but first, what do these
terms mean exactly?
Let’s perform four experiments, and after
you watch them, I promise that you will understand
all about them.
Let’s look at the rigid bodies first in
experiment number one.
Iron box versus magnet.
We are starting out slow, and now, we are
waiting for the attraction to kick in, and
there we go.
Wonderful.
Experiment number two, deformable magnetic
bodies.
In other words, magnetic lotus versus a moving
magnet.
This one is absolutely beautiful, look at
how the the petals here are modeled as thin
elastic sheets that dance around in the presence
of a moving magnet.
And if you think this is dancing, stay tuned,
there will be an example with even better
dance moves in a moment.
And experiment number three, two-way coupling.
We noted this coupling thing earlier, so,
what does that mean?
What coupling means is that here, the water
can have an effect on the magnet, and the
two-way part means that in return, the magnet
can also have an effect on the water as well.
This is excellent, because we don’t have
to think about the limitations of the simulation,
we can just drop nearly anything into our
simulation domain, be it a fluid, solid, magnetic
or not, and we can expect that their interactions
are going to be modeled properly.
Outstanding.
And, I promised some more dancing, so here
goes, experiment number four, the dancing
ferrofluid.
I love how informative the compass is here,
it is a simple object that tells us how an
external magnetic field evolves over time.
I love this elegant solution.
Normally, we have to visualize the magnetic
induction lines so we can better see why the
tentacles of a magnetic octopus move, or why
two ferrofluid droplets repel or attract each
other.
In this case, the authors opted for a much
more concise and elegant solution, and I also
liked that the compass is not just a 2D overlay,
but a properly shaded 3D object with specular
reflections as well.
Excellent attention to detail.
This is really my kind of paper.
Now, these simulations were not run on any
kind of supercomputer or a network of computers,
this runs on the processor of your consumer
machine at home.
However, simulating even the simpler scenes
takes hours.
For more complex scenes, even days.
And that’s not all, the ferrofluid with
the Yin-Yang symbol took nearly a month to
compute.
So, is that a problem?
No, no, of course not.
Not in the slightest.
Thanks to this paper, general magnetic simulations
that were previous impossible are now possible,
and don’t forget, research is a process.
As you saw in the example at the start of
this video with the surface-only ferrofluid
formulation, it may become much faster just
one more paper down the line.
I wanted to show you the first two papers
in this video to demonstrate how quickly that
can happen.
And two more papers down the line, oh my,
then, the sky is the limit.
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!